I've got a great recommendation for you
today this is something a little bit
different I've been recommending a lot
of nonfiction books and fiction books
etc I recently watched a pilot episode
of an amazon original called oasis
there's a lot of really bad sci-fi out
there Pat and when there's actually some
good sci-fi produced I really like it
and want to recommend it to people and
Amazon has done just a single pilot
episode so far called
oasis and the concept is that it's 2032
London and that there's been a sort of
dystopian collapse of sorts there's a
shortage of food and supplies and after
the death of his wife a chaplain is
contacted by an executive from a an
extra planetary colony that is being
called the Oasis and is being developed
and built and he is summoned and he
agrees to go up there and the story of
the first episode sort of follows some
of what is going on up there and sort of
ends of course on a cliffhanger which
would lend itself to probably a really
great full season of shows this is an
Amazon original so if you have Amazon
Prime I think even if you don't have
Prime you can get like the individual
episode really really good really good
and I don't know if you like this type
of show I'm super into like I hate
crappy sci-fi but like really good
sci-fi I'm into so like the the most
recent iteration of Battlestar Galactica
tremendous and I think Sam cedar for
majority report agrees with me on that
one good sci-fi I'm into and this is
really really well done well what I like
about this concept is that you know a
lot of times people will recommend TV
shows to me and I'm just kind of
overwhelmed because maybe there's
several seasons of that show and I just
look at it as a big to-do yeah the
lovely one pilot episode I mean I don't
really have too many complaints there's
nothing holding me back so you're saying
it's fair to say that you're drawn to
this not because of the subject matter
but because of the duration right and I
know that you know regardless of if I
like the first episode or not it will be
done with yeah so as of right now I
don't know whether there's been a
decision about whether to go forward
with the entire season or not I'm
mentioning it to you in the audience so
that hopefully you'll watch this
pilot episode of oasis my guess is that
if you go into it with an open mind
whether or not you like science fiction
you will like it and you will contact
Amazon and ask them to make the full
season although you know my guess is you
don't even really need to contact Amazon
they're probably able to decide whether
it's worth making the full season just
based on how many people watch it well
if it's good enough so for you to
recommend it then I'm sure it's a good
enough show for them to make more
episodes I like your confidence in my
taste absolutely generally are you a
sci-fi guy or is that not a genre that
you really never been a drawn room
intrude what is our genre that you're
interested Oracle fiction really yeah
okay so my last week's recommendation of
Allen firsts book a hero of France that
would be sort of up your alley I'd like
to report to you that I have read and
completed that book by now but
unfortunately at this point I cannot
you've put it on the list of books to
consider possibly looking at by at some
future point or something like that
right okay on the bonus show today we
are going to be talking about more than
80% of Americans can't find Arab
countries on a map and it is not because
they don't have maps referencing of
course miss Deane Miss Teen South
Carolina Steen South Carolina
yeah Chechnya is police are telling
parents to kill their gay sons or they
will do it themselves it's a crisis
what's going on in Chechnya right now
around LGBT rights and the woman finds a
note from a believed Chinese prisoner in
her purse that she bought at Walmart is
it real is it not
you know Walmart's position on it I'm
guessing you can guess what it is we
will discuss all of those stories and
more on the bonus show you can also find
me on Twitter at Dee Pakman and you can
find the show at david pakman show